good morning believe nation today's
message is don't give yourself
boundaries over you Idris Elba I mean
it's important not to give yourself
boundaries which we can do quite easily
okay people talk about aiming for the
skies
sometimes even aiming for the skies is
intimidating just don't give yourself
boundaries your sky and my sky might be
different you know I mean but neither of
us would touch the sky if we give
ourselves boundaries you know I mean
whatever your sky is whatever your
biggest dream is I might have already
touched that you know so in other words
what sky where does the sky end I'd
rather people go you know what I'm not
gonna restrict myself to the guy and I
can only do this so I can only do that
oh I have to do it this way all I have
to do it that way I think it's important
that people just go and lose the
boundaries lose the conformity and just
go for it I think the biggest thing that
holds people back holds you back are the
limited beliefs that you have for
yourself the boundaries that you set for
yourself the the box that you create for
yourselves a lot of entrepreneurs think
I know I'm not inside the box right I
left that big job at that safe company
because I didn't want to be told what to
do or I didn't want to live inside a box
but then you come and you start your own
business and you create your own box
right if you know you don't have a boss
telling you what to do you've created
this own box and the walls are the
limiting beliefs you have and we all
have them and we all need to break free
of them I mean when I was first getting
started the first you know the first
boundaries I had were I'm too young to
do this nobody's gonna listen to me I
can't sell this to people who are three
times my age and so I didn't want to
meet anybody face to face didn't want to
have phone calls then as I grew I
thought no I don't want to do
presentations I'm too nervous I was
gonna want to hear my story when I was
doing interviews like well why would
they want to hear my message when I was
talking to big companies or what do I
have to offer a huge company like
Microsoft why would they want to listen
to
me and it was only by breaking through
those boundaries that I was able to
achieve more success I was able to
actually achieve my goals and I realized
nobody's actually creating those
boundaries that myself those other
people all the cameras can I provide
value to them right and and I could and
when I realized that and sometimes those
boundaries were were holding me to act
for a couple months sometimes a couple
years some of them I still have you know
every time I realize it that's the step
to be able to break free and I think you
know if you have so many boundaries so
many restrictions on yourself the way to
get started is when you find yourself
telling yourself a story constantly like
I can't do this because that's usually a
trigger that you want to try to make
that a trigger where it's is that
actually real right is that just in my
head or is that something that actually
exists and often it's just a story
you're telling yourself and we're really
smart we're really capable of lying to
ourselves and convincing ourselves that
we can't do something because of X Y Z
and so what I want you to do is start
getting used to breaking those
boundaries start recognizing awareness
is the first step having the awareness
that you're holding yourself back in
this moment if you can do that in a
moment and not later because later is
the regret right leaders who regret
where you think about oh I should have
done this why don't I do that that was
so stupid I was too scared I really and
you lived your life with regret if you
can catch it in the moment and then try
to do something about it one small step
towards saying yes to doing it even
though it's scary even though it's
nerve-wracking even though you may fail
doing it if you can consistently do that
and get in the habit of catching
yourself then you'll expand your box and
hopefully break through the boundaries
and achieve the goals that you want to
achieve so the question of the day today
is what are the boundaries that you've
set for yourself that are holding you
back going deep leaving the comments
below
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
we go